this is a production of cornell
university
the the nation these plants are very
rhythmic
okay so think of skunk cabbage of jack
in the pulpit
your experience with much smaller
versions of this this is you know if
georgia o'keeffe could have done this
she would have
but this plant wasn't as popular at that
during her heyday than
as it is now now it's as we were
discussing before it's a little bit of a
growth industry and
greenhouses and botanical gardens around
the world um
one of the things i've been telling my
colleagues
in my own field is that the the draw of
this plant is not
that other flowers do this the draw of
this plant is that it has a hold
on the human imagination okay it has
charisma it fills rooms we're going to
have thousands of people come see this
so the outreach opportunity is not that
crop plants do this
and honey bees like this the outreach
opportunity is that this
is a bigger than life example of what it
takes
for plants to reproduce okay huge i mean
paul can show you the quorum
this is a like literal investment in in
mass
of stored sun power you know in as
starch
and what it takes to marshal all that
into this unbelievable effort of
flowering
and the fact that it's gone after three
days is
is is is you know almost mythological
to me so what we're really interested in
and i try to talk to students about
is that the plant is almost behaving
okay most plant biology happens so
slowly
uh and and so under our noses that we
don't we think of them as passive
right but what this plant is doing is
very active
it's growing fast enough for you to see
it
okay you come back every day and you see
oh okay it's three inches taller
it's wider it's heavier it's marshaling
all this energy
when it blooms this has been called on
the literature d-day
you know because of the incredible
explosion
of heat and stink and and in the visual
display this this skirt the spathe
becomes a beautiful purple funnel
um william barthevolt in in in germany
has actually
modeled with engineers the idea that it
might actually be a convection
chimney okay since since this whole
plant is
strongly thermogenic it's it's heating
up to eight to ten degrees
centigrade above ambient why on earth is
it doing that why is it doing it from
sunset on d-day to midnight which is
when it happens and we have thermal
images from two years ago showing
beautifully in color coding how this
thing gets really hot
but if you look at the the spade around
it
and realize that that the active part of
the flower
biology is down here in this little
chamber of these tiny little florets
what it's doing is it's heating as it's
emitting scent
and the convection currents that would
be produced by that would actually carry
that scent
up into the forest canopy and away from
the forest floor
in a rain forest okay it's very stable
place rainforest understories don't have
a lot of wind
all right so a rafflesia flower in the
same
habitat you know in tropical asia
very large very stinky not as strongly
heated or thermogenic the odor there
would bleb off in the boundary layer
and diffuse along the forest floor where
beetles and
and flies that come to dead animals
would perceive it and fly to the flower
and there's lots of nice david
attenborough footage of what happens to
rafflesia flowers and borneo and sumatra
etc
what the the german study was so why
that was so interesting to us was the
idea that
this plant may have a different niche
growing in the same forest it might be
advertising to
carry on insects up at the canopy
rather than down on the forest floor
using physics
basically creating a chimney and so one
of these we've been interested in
is what's the schedule why are they
producing
their blast of heat and scent at dusk
on d-day why does that persist until
midnight
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu